good afternoon everyone
my name is priyana tarajan i'm a faculty
member in the departments of astronomy
and physics at yale and i also serve as
the current director of the university's
flagship interdisciplinary program the
frankie program in science and the
humanities
i am delighted to invite you all
to today's talk by a brilliant colleague
professor hazel carby
and this talk is part of the frankie
program's distinguished speaker series
but before i introduce her i would like
to begin by first thanking our
benefactors mr and mrs richard and
barbara frankie who have joined us today
and whose generosity enables this unique
cross-disciplinary engagement and
conversations and collaborations that
transcend traditional academic
disciplinary boundaries
also i would like to remind all of you
that as we are recording this event i
would like to request you all to mute
your audio and videos
if you wish uh please feel free to start
submitting questions
through the q a feature
and
and hazel will take your questions after
finishing her talk
now to today's wonderful speaker
hazel reek harvey is the charles c and
dorothea dilly professor emeritus of
african american studies and professor
emeritus of american studies at yale
university she's also a fellow of the
royal society for the arts she's
currently a visiting research professor
and humanities institute faculty at
dartmouth college
her research work has focused on race
gender
and sexuality in caribbean and diasporic
culture and literature
and her work has centered on
transnational and post-colonial
literature and theory
in representations examining the
representations of the black female body
and
in the genres of science fiction
her work engages deeply
with and interrogates the discrepancies
between the symbolic constructions of
the black experience
and the actual lived lives of african
americans a pioneering voice and
formidable intellect in black feminism
she is recognized as one of the world's
leading scholars on race and gender one
of her most influential contributions to
african diaspora studies came with her
very first book
reconstructing womanhood the emergence
of the afro-american woman novelist
published in 1987.
formidable scholar she is the recipient
of many awards and honors she is notably
the author of several award-winning
books including imperial intimacies a
tale of two islands published by verso
in 2019 selected as one of the books of
the year for 2019 by the times literary
supplement she is also the winner of
british academy's knife and rhoden prize
for global cultural understanding
and awarded in 2020. further recognition
of her work includes her selection as a
finalist for the john pope franklin
publication prize
uh in 2020. also
in last year her book imperial
intimacies earned recognition in the
highly commended category of the penn
hessel tiltman prize i could go on and
on reading out all her wonderful
achievements honours and awards but
without further ado
i am really excited to hear from her
today so on to you hazel and we are so
thankful that you accepted our
invitation to speak uh at the frankie
program
thank you very much priya i'm just going
to uh share my screen
so um thank you very much for the
invitation to give this lecture um it's
actually drawn from the book that you
were talking about priya
imperial intimacies
which i like to describe as a very
british story
it's a story of the everyday ties
relations and
what i think of as intricate
interdependencies of an empire and
colonialism
it does not conform to the way in which
most stories of empire have been told
and it questions what we think we know
about our shared colonial past
i incorporate stories of my welsh mother
my jamaican father and their ancestors
one of whom you'll hear about today into
material drawn from colonial archives in
histories
to show how they were shaped
by the times and the places in which
they lived
but family stories and historical
accounts
can actually sit very uneasily side by
side
when i assembled the various pieces
i found that rather than cohere into a
unified narrative
their juxtaposition revealed the shards
of conflict
and contradiction
that familial
national and imperial ideologies work to
conceal
i used family memories as a guide to
navigate material in the national
archives of jamaica
and the uk
but when i stumbled i had to put aside
the voices of my relatives
because they hindered my ability to see
what they had disguised
what they had hidden
and what they had absolutely no
intention of passing on
so imperial intimacies is an account
written from the perspective
of someone of jamaican welsh ancestry
who does not take for granted
definitions of being british
but rather is interested in how subjects
become british
and how people are inscribed
into ideologies of empire and beliefs of
whiteness
that enable them to feel superior
even when they are desperately poor
the story of imperial relations
is as restless as the atlantic surging
between the islands of britain and
jamaica
and i follow currents that draw me back
into the eighth the mid-18th century we
won't be going back that far today
basically today i'm going to be
concentrating on an area
at the end of the
end of the 19th century in the early
20th century
uh but the book is also anchored in the
particular places
in which people in my family lived and
died
the urban centers of london bath
bristol cardiff and kingston
and the rural landscapes of devon
somerset
lincolnshire and portland
it's not an exceptional story about
becoming british
but it's
instead it really asserts that
britishness
harbors the deepest
interconnections of class and race and
gender
trying to find your way as the white
mother of a black child for example
trying to survive as a black child in a
colony and a black man in the metropole
and being a girl who was regarded as an
oxymoron
when she claimed she was both black and
british
so i'm going to begin with this quote by
stuart hall
he said identity is not only a story
a narrative which we tell ourselves
about ourselves
it is a story it is stories
which change with historical
circumstances
and identity shifts with the way in
which we think and hear them and
experience them
far from only coming from the still
small point of truth inside us
identities actually come from outside
they are the way in which we are
recognized
and then come to step into
the place of the recognitions which
others give us
without the others
there is no self
there is no
self recognition
so today i'm actually going to give an
example of how in the book i i use and
complicate this question of identity
um the example will be from bristol
and in terms of the place and the
example of the character will be the
person i um
know as but also imagine as and have
created as uh my grandmother
all the stories i was told by relatives
anchor my maternal family's identity in
bristol
the west country and wales
but i know that my grandmother her name
was beatrice williams
must have felt that she also belonged to
the larger world of the british empire
and one of my questions is how was her
sense of self
shaped by her environment
and what did she know
of the city's past
bristol had been intimately entangled
with the colonial world for centuries
so how did beatrice come to understand
herself as a british subject
who was part of an empire that ruled
over a third of the globe
i lean in through time and space
to tap my grandmother on the shoulder
and speak to her
as she turns towards me
i ask beatrice if she is like her
granddaughter
if the streets of the city are her
avenue of escape as they were to the
girl
i make beatrice explore every inch of
her city
as her granddaughter explored hers
when my grandmother had the time to
leave her neighborhood of bedminster
cross the river aven and explore the
city center
she would have walked up e street
crossing the new cut on the bedminster
bridge
on her way to the prince street bridge
which is an iron swing bridge that
crosses the floating harbour
she would have passed this street
guinea street near the docks
was beatrice aware of the derivation of
the name guinea
once the site of the homes of men who
traded in human flesh
the street's name resonates with
associations
not only to the west african coast
but to the kind of exchange
used by the royal african company
the built environment of the center of
bristol still exudes
self-satisfied achievement in character
and appearance
the architectural grandeur and the grace
of public institutions and
residential squares
is ample evidence of centuries of
accumulated wealth
when beatrice was a young woman
the city appeared to wear its history on
its surfaces
but for centuries
bristol's public face
hid the ignominious origins of its
wealth
without exception
my maternal relatives
revered bristol
they lived and worked in its poorest
districts but they emulated the solid
respectability
of its wealthy citizens
my grandmother's desire to achieve
a driving ambition she instilled in my
mother her daughter
has its roots here in bristol a city
that nurtured and nourished the dreaming
of strivers
bristol had an exceptionally robust
civic culture embedded in libraries
schools
museums and theaters which encouraged
and confirmed ambition
and proffered a sense of entitlement to
its citizens
even if beatrice was unable to afford
tickets
to actually attend a theater
the library was free as were lectures
lantern slide shows and many other
public events
for a young woman whose working life was
confined to domestic labor
the wealth of civic life offered scope
for her imagination
however unattainable
the city held promise for a future
becoming modern
and becoming educated
i believe that beatrice's fierce
determination to send her own daughter
to a fine high school for girls was
stimulated by the flourishing
educational institutions
that she saw around her
including
colston girls school and here the
university college of bristol which
became bristol university
in 1909
it was the city's wealthy merchant
philanthropists and large stable
bourgeoisie
that had endowed bristol with its
libraries its schools and universities
and with the 18th century georgian
architecture of its monumental civic
buildings
broad avenues and substantial houses
nourished by its civic pride
bristol made strivers of my maternal
ancestors all of whom clung to the
ethics and the values
of bourgeois aspiration
if they felt
a strong allegiance in fact to the
british bourgeoisie even though they
could never ever achieve its level of
financial wealth
only when i became an adult
was i able to distinguish
between the subtleties and the
variations of allegiance
the multiple meanings of bristol in the
particular lives and individual pasts of
my relatives
bristol exerted symbolic power for them
in its promise for the future
the possibility of progress was the
realization and fulfillment of a
peculiar form of british dreaming
and gradually i learned to question the
foundation
upon which
british dreams of futurity and british
dreams of belonging
were built
promise flourished
because it was grounded in and generated
by the wealth and the stability visible
in the bricks and mortar of everyday
bristol life
constructed by the city's merchants
the architecture
clearly was testimony to british success
in trade
to the ethics of hard work
the value of profit
and imperial power
concealed
was the source of that profit
the enslaved labor that financed the
city's economy in the 18th from the 18th
century onwards
and which paved the way
for bristol's modernity
the enslaved labor that enabled its
georgian grace
founded its civic culture
and made possible
its philanthropic works
sugar
and cocoa
were integral
to britain's to bristol's economy
and its culture
the city was noted for its chocolate and
confectionary works which alongside
tobacco factories employed large numbers
of its residents
the structures that were emblems of the
city's modernity however
physically disguised the roots of its
wealth
in enslavement
and continued colonial oppression
centuries
of brutal exploitation of african
peoples enabled the philanthropy that
brought enormous benefit
as well as civic grace to this english
city
and its citizens
the wills family a tobacco family became
abolitionists eventually
and yet they donated the profits of
enslavement
to the city of bristol
not to the enslaved who had labored to
grow
and harvest
the tobacco they sold
the city's abolitionist hero
edward colston
considered bristol's great benefactor
built schools arms houses hospitals and
churches with money that he had accrued
from the trade in enslaved human beings
while a member of the royal african
company and the society of merchant
ventures
sorry merch adventurers i should say
colston girls school
was recently renamed actually montpelier
high school
after this statue of edward colston was
unceremoniously
dumped in the bristol harbor
was deeply bound to the enslavement and
transportation of africans in the
atlantic trade
but it is misleading to reduce this
history to the economic activities of a
few
wealthy individuals or traders
beatrice and her family passed by
and went in and out of bristol schools
libraries and churches but nothing
enabled them to see
the connection between trading in human
beings and bristol's history its wealth
and civic culture
impressed by the grand georgian houses
of queen square
royal crest royal york crescent and
clifton
they regarded the buildings as
confirmation of achievement
the realization of ambition
and success in business
now profits to bristol and its citizens
were enormous
both from the export of their goods to
the african coast for the purchase of
human beings
and from the resale
of human chattel in the caribbean
a financial outline a financial outlay
by merchants
of
660 pounds
could reap a profit
of 1
000 percent
minus the cost of transportation
a plantation owner for an outlay of 31
pounds
purchased an enormous amount
of labor power
investment in the trade was only one
source of profits that accrued to
bristol
residents of the city could reap
financial gain
from participation in the myriad trades
related to transatlantic slavery
through investment
or employment
producing goods for export to africa and
the american slave colonies
servicing and manning the ships that
left bristol on transatlantic voyages
refining in bristol the products of
slave labor
and handling sugar and tobacco cargos
from plantation colonies
the trade in enslaved people was closely
interwoven with the wider commercial and
economic
fabric of the city
in the late 18th century
at least 40 percent of the income of
bristolians
derived from slavery related activities
it was not only the merchants
trading in enslaved human beings
who profited but barrel makers
brothel keepers
chandlers
candle makers carpenters
dock workers
innkeepers lawn dresses
sailors sail makers and shoemakers
so you get my point everyone benefited
bristol was a city produced
in circuits of exchange with
with jamaica
if the history
of bristol's financial dreams
has been intimately tied to the
enslavement of others
it is also true
that at the center of this intimacy
was the island of jamaica
in
1655
oliver cromwell seized jamaica from the
spanish
initiating british imperial rule
of a nation that would become one of the
world's leading
sugar exporting slave-driven countries
and establishing the close economic
relationship
between bristol and jamaica for sugar
tobacco and the trade in enslaved humans
the relationship this relationship
transformed and enriched
both bristol
and jamaica planters
because jamaica was the largest sugar
island in the british caribbean
and traditionally the best market for
slaves transported in bristol ships
the total number of africans who were
forcibly dragged aboard british ships in
chains will never be known and exact
numbers are not available for the 2106
ships
that left bristol for the african coast
and from there sailed with their human
cargo to the caribbean
901 of these ships sailed to jamaica
although final inventories are not
available for bristol ships
historians estimate that 587
000 africans were enslaved and that 486
000 or 82.8 percent
landed alive in the americas
from the
1591 voyages to the caribbean
445 thousand four hundred and eighty
seven
enslaved humans
were embarked onto bristol ships
and three thousand seven hundred
for sorry and three hundred and seventy
one thousand
three 306
disembarked
217
263 of them
were landed
in jamaica
i seek a reckoning
with these
inventories
i have to find a way
to decipher the apparently unfathomable
oceanic computation
in which my ancestors remain shackled
among these anonymous hundreds of
thousands
penned in black ink on graph paper
are girls and women
who survived the middle passage
and are sold in port antonia jamaica
where they will become the property of a
man
called carby
but just as beatrice is unable to
recognize the past in her present
neither can she imagine a future
in which her daughter will marry a
descendant of this man
and one of these women
as beatrice grew from child to adult
the most pervasive ideology of modernity
was the new imperialism
of late victorian and edwardian britain
this was a period of massive and rapid
territorial expansion for the industrial
countries of western europe who in
competition with each other sought new
colonial acquisitions
and the consolidation of their control
over indigenous peoples in africa asia
and the pacific
through image and spectacle beatrice
would not only have become conscious
of the vast reach of the british empire
but would also have been introduced
into the racial logics of whiteness
did she become convinced of the
superiority of imperial power
and did she believe despite her poverty
that she was a member of a superior race
destined to rule
over a third of the globe
so one of the most popular forms of
entertainment was the magic lantern
but lantern slide shows were also
quickly recognized for their educational
potential in schools where they were
used for teaching geography history and
science
their teacher of bath road board school
in bristol for example built a
collection of over 2 000 slides for use
in the classroom
lantern shows
infinitely expanded the spatial and the
geographical sorry the spatial and the
geographical horizons
of everyday life
in 1902
a visual instruction committee was set
up by the secretary of state for the
colonies
to produce lantern slides on the uk
for use
in the territories of its empire
and five years later
the committee embarked on a scheme
to provide lecture materials for use in
british schools
but imperialism
and the racism which was its primary
characteristic
existed in many forms of lantern slides
in school classrooms
in town and village halls
the magic lantern shows
projected the racism and imperialism of
the age
justifying the need for
and the rightness of british rule
in their portrayal of the peoples of the
empire
and of military exploits in colonial
wars in egypt and the sudan
south africa
and india
in 1897
hand tinted lantern slides of queen
victoria's diamond jubilee was shown
all over the country
and the initial slide you saw at the
beginning of this lecture is one of
those
these shows were visual enactments
and effective realizations of
imperialism
watching the jingoistic spectacle of
colonial genuflection to the mother of
empire
generated patriotic emotion and desire
the sequences of ceremonial procession
were manifestations of colonial
possession
and scenes of general joy
an unbounded loyalty of the visceral
pleasure of dwelling in and belonging to
what was called greater britain
local stores
not only invoked colonialism in their
names like the british and colonial meat
company
but they also signaled a shift
away from dependence on domestic
agriculture
toward the increasing importation of
food
the home and colonial tea stores
began as a trading association in 1885
and by 1903
had over 400 retail outlets in britain
including a branch here on e street in
bedminster where my grandmother lived
in addition to tea they sold a narrow
range of products
sugar bacon hair margarine and butter
but increase their profit margin
through ownership of their producers
and their processors overseas as well as
in the uk
their shop counters
had rows of compartments filled with
different varieties of tea from
plantations developed in india and sri
lanka which was then called the crown
colony of salon
here is a jubilee handkerchief
retail stalls with multiple outlets
competed for urban shoppers through
competitive pricing and long opening
hours
although they aimed to attract the
working class
beatrice would not have entered these
stores
she could only stare through their
windows
for they protected their profits by
refusing to issue credit on which the
poor depended
but there was so much to see
even from outside
since window displays formed a rich
street culture of colonial information
and advertising
the companies that adopted innovative
innovative advertising techniques
were those whose goods were at the heart
of the imperial economy
tea
chocolate
soaps
and oils
tobacco
and meat extracts
biscuit tins
chocolate wrappings
mugs and tea cloths
commemorated coronations
and the jubilee
reproduced colonial flags
and used celebratory images of british
royalty and military might
though the family could not possibly
have afforded to purchase them
commemorative mugs and biscuit and
chocolate tins
would have brightened the shelves
of their home
in their railway cottage
because they were distributed free
to school children
being one of the prime means by which
school boards encouraged patriotism
in children
the windows of news agents
were festooned with visual
representations of the empire on which
the sun never sets
including picture postcards
and juvenile papers
with images of colonial adventures which
were widely circulated through the
practice of swapping
individual issues
young people
young people were also
absolutely avid collectors
of cigarette cards
on e street sat the large factory of wd
and h.o wills
the largest manufacturer of tobacco
products
which incorporated 12 other companies to
form the imperial tobacco company in
1901
the cigarette cards they produced
were perhaps the most influential form
of collectible
imperial propaganda
combining visual and textual information
with clear pedagogic intent
they were issued in series
and blank albums were sold to mount and
display the cards
there were a number of card series is
devoted to all aspects of empire
including arms like you see here
flags builders of empire britain's
defenders
children of all nations
indian regiments
governor general's
engineering wonders army life and the
royal navy
for beatrice
as for her generation
a prerequisite of being a modern british
citizen
was being an imperial subject
visual spectacle generated and confirmed
their patriotism
their loyalty
not only to nation but to empire
the aggressive expansion
and the maintenance of territorial
dominance
necessitated war in far-flung regions
the significance of which was brought
home
through public celebrations of military
might
the return of units of the british army
from the boer war in 1902
were occasions for patriotic spectacle
as they paraded through the streets of
cities and towns
all over the country
mitchell and kenyon a lancashire-based
film company who were pioneers in the
production of british motion pictures
traveled south to produce a film of the
crowds gathered in bristol to greet the
return of war hero
lord methuen
despite of his numerous failures on the
battlefield
for beatrice like many others
this would have been her first
experience
of witnessing the making of a of a
moving picture
death
as you see here also occasions
spectacles of patriotic sentiment
aimed at cementing local ties
to soldiers killed thousands of miles
away
in bristol
large groups of spectators
were drawn to the pomp and ceremony
surrounding the 1905
unveiling of the boer war memorial
in honor of the gloucester regiment
garrisoned in the city of bristol
beginning in 1902
empire day was celebrated annually on
the 24th of may
and the british empire league
furnished schools with
with flags
this was
beatrice's last year in school actually
and she would have been among the
students who performed in the patriotic
plays
and processions which were supported by
local councils who contributed to
refreshments and commemorative mugs
these are also lucrative occasions for
lantern slide makers
who would photograph the children and
their activities and then sell the shows
to the schools
pageants celebrating empire were held in
bristol throughout the decade
and one of the most spectacular is
recorded on a postcard
this
where hundreds of children
formed a living union jack
in victoria park
did beatrice
or her mother rose my great-grandmother
know about jamaica and jamaicans
other than what could be found on the
back of a wills cigarette card
my maternal relatives
were vehemently
implacably
opposed to the relationship between my
mother and the jamaican airmen who would
become my father
their understanding of their allegiance
to empire
their belonging
as white
imperial
racially superior british subjects
was formed maintained
and reinforced
in these
mundane details of daily life
in shopping
storing biscuits
and drinking tea
what could have exposed the history of
violence and exploitation
that bound bristol and jamaica
beatrice may have noticed a poster
advertising
jamaica the new riviera on a museum
board
or in the window of the dunsken optical
lantern and photographic store on
saint augustine parade
i imagine
her carefully noting the place date and
time of the lantern show
which promised vibrant images of a
beautiful island of luxurious vegetation
lovely scenery refreshed by invigorating
sea breezes
james johnson's lecturing tours in the
uk between 1901 and 1903
were part of a larger capitalist project
of colonial modernization
and heralded
the opening of a new
shipping service
between bristol and jamaica
under contract with the imperial direct
line
joseph chamberlain who was secretary of
state for the colonies from 1895 to 1903
was the leader
of those advocating for a new
imperialism
and he was the architect of programs for
its implementation
he was convinced that britain had to
ensure its economic future
and military dominance through closer
links with the colonies and the
expansion of empire
chamberlain actually was the one who
organized the celebration of britain's
first diamond jubilee in 1897
as an imperial spectacle because he
understood
how empire could be visualized and how
it could be enacted how it could be
harnessed
for its ideological potential to secure
the affiliation and the allegiance of
british citizens
chamberlain financed a coterie of
imperialist men
in a plan to increase trade
and open jamaica to tourism
bristol was the fulcrum of this plan
which was intended to
impel jamaica to become modern
by which was meant
becoming a more profitable
colony
to this end the british government
awarded alfred lewis jones
managing director of the liverpool-based
elder dempster shipping company a
contract to take over all steamships
running between the west indies and the
uk
jones was to form a new shipping line
the imperial direct west india mail
company to run between bristol and
kingston
and open a transatlantic market
introducing bananas
to the british
and the wealthy british
to jamaica
chamberlain promised to subsidize the
venture if jones would take the leading
role
in promoting a new jamaica
and building a market in the uk
in the 1750s
luxury items like chocolate and coffee
were available in the shops of bristol
during the early years of the 20th
century
the british public were to be persuaded
to
consume bananas
and dream
of jamaica
i wonder
if beatrice or her sister moored
purchased bananas from a cart
being wheeled down a bristol street here
by a black man selling the fruit at two
for a penny happening
would the sisters have stood stock still
at such a sight would they have been
taken aback
were the black residents of bristol a
familiar sight to them
so common that they took their presence
their presence for granted
an african banana skin
dated in fact to approximately 1460
was discovered during excavations at the
museum of london in 1999
and a bunch from bermuda was displayed
in the window of a london herbalist
in 1663
but bananas were not
regularly imported into the uk
until 1884
and were not widely available until the
early 20th century
the closely woven political economic
social
and cultural ties
between jamaica and england formed an
imperial intimacy
that had been rendered historically
invisible by the turn of the 20th
century
but
bananas
were the tangible evidence of a
connection
or perhaps not
my mother's generation would have taken
for granted the presence of sugar in
their tea and chocolate and tobacco in
their shops just as they took for
granted the tea itself
but bananas all
imported through bristol appear
throughout the nation during beatrice's
teenage years
and their presence needed to be
explained
the banana must have seemed
such an exotic fruit at first sight
if beatrice knew what bananas were
did she have an image of jamaica in her
mind as she unpeeled one and tasted it
was a black banana cellar a commonplace
site
what would beatrice have known
about kingston
the city from which imperial direct
ships exported bananas to bristol at a
rate of 30 000 bunches
of fortnite
minstrel shows and troops of jubilee
singers from the united states regularly
toured the uk
and they performed in bristol in the
latter half of the 19th century
here in 1886 the great american slave
troop and brass band with 16 real
negroes
mounted parades throughout the streets
the day they arrived
and they performed free serenades
outside the old theater royal each day
before their show
black performers were to be found all
over the uk
in the victorian and edwardian periods
at carnivals
and on the stage in vaudevilles and
theaters
alfred jones also arranged here for the
kingston coral union of jamaica
to make three tours of the uk between
1906 and 1908
they traveled to and from jamaica on his
ships which ducked in avonmouth
from here the kingston coral union
traveled by train to tour cities and
towns all over the country
in 1908 they performed in wales and the
west country
even if beatrice and moore did not go to
the theater they would have seen posters
and postcards announcing their
performances
confronted by a banana seller
did beatrice hesitate
and furrow her brow in concentration
trying to imagine where such fruit or
such people had come from
would her
curiosity have impelled her into a
lantern slide show about jamaica
my mother learnt to dream of jamaica in
her own way but
perhaps beatrice also instilled in her
daughter
a particular form
of english colonial
dreaming
chamberlain and jones
employed james johnston
a jamaican missionary
an alfred lead
an amateur photographer from bristol
to photograph the landscape of jamaica
as a space of desire in the british
imagination
the camera was a technology essential to
colonial projects of modernization
lantern slideshows
inducted crowds into a particularly
modern form of individual and collective
subjectivity
forever changing the ways in which the
world was known
the metropolitan subject
learnt to become a tourist
even without the means to travel
they learned to observe others as
objects susceptible to their mastery
knowledge of the limitations of their
existence
the misery of their daily realities
melted
into fascination absorption and
longing in the effenescent light of
modern day colonies
and foreign landscapes
the first hurdle to be overcome
in representing jamaica as a new riviera
was the entrenched belief that the
island was a site of disease
tormenting insects parasites
and a recalcitrant black population
in order to see for myself what verbal
strategies johnston employed to
accomplish this transformation i had to
visit the library at the university of
cambridge
sitting reading his script
my mind traveled back in time to bristol
in 1903
where i sat with my grandmother in a
darkened auditorium
johnston advised all amateur lecturers
to tell their stories in a natural
conversational free and easy style which
would put them in touch with their
listeners
fixing the attention and carrying them
along with you
in the dark
we are captivated by johnston's words
mesmerized by the glow of image after
image passing in front of our eyes
and hypnotized by the soothing voice
which molds how we see
the audience boards the ss port antonio
one of the palatial yachts of the
imperial direct west india mail service
and we are transported from the gray
skies cold and damp climate of bristol
to the port of kingston the most
important city in the west indies
set against the backdrop of the
magnificent range of the blue mountains
we arrive
on a beautiful island of luxurious
vegetation and lovely scenery
refreshed by invigorating sea breezes
where it is possible to enjoy
a degree of health and life
such is found
nowhere else
we experience a reality so intense
it renders our lives mundane
[Music]
we travel from the harbour to the
constant spring hotel on the tramway of
the canadian-owned west india electric
company
and once there we look across the
ligonaire plains
to a sea view of unrivaled beauty
the caribbean
in glorious tints of el emerald and blue
and collectively hold our breath
moonlight brings
enchantment
we are lulled to sleep breathing air
laden with the perfume of flowers
and listening to the murmuring fronds of
the graceful palm tree
the next morning we travel along halfway
tree road
where the fields and folia just soon a
deeper green
the glare is less and the air freshens
as we ascend the hill toward castleton
gardens
on the journey
we are enticed by the synchronicity
of language and sight
crowds of women and children walking
briskly along with their baskets on
their heads carrying yams plantains
potatoes bread fruit limes lemons
oranges
pineapples coconuts mangoes shadow
grapefruits poor pores melons custard
apples sweet sop soursops rose apples
saber dillas cherry moya grandillas
cashews chocos
tamarins avocado pears poultry and eggs
etc
destined for a market in kingston
words
tumble upon words
in johnston's recitation
overwhelming us with a sense of
abundance
we take pleasure in the quant in the
quality of their
strangeness of the alien and the
unexplored the weight and the wealth of
their accumulation
the resonance of sound and image
produce
an erotic delight
what does it matter if we do not
understand what we see in here
what matters is what we feel
the
sensuality of excess
we find ourselves perched above the lush
vegetation of castleton gardens
jamaica's famous botanical garden
looking down
upon a public footpath
there is a mountain in the distance
the perspective exaggerates the size of
the foliage and the vegetation while
dwarfing the human and the social
our eyes follow a path of light from our
high vantage point to a man and a woman
standing apart where the paths converge
surrounded by palms pines and banana
trees that diminish
them behind the man in a white shirt a
tree casts a solid shadow diagonally
diagonally
across the path
we are starting to find
another person almost but
not quite hidden in dappled shade
a shadow delineates the folds of the
woman's skirt
and runs into the ground
we have the impression that these people
are as rooted in place
as the enormous trunks of the trees
which tower over them
we experience castleton guns
both as a study of detail
and as a curious absence of detail we're
unable to distinguish any of the
features of a human face
but the palm fronds are sharply defined
etched in sharp contrasts of light and
dark
we then find ourselves
at a lily pond
where to northern eyes the abundance and
productivity of the natural world
verges on the alien chaotic and out of
control
like the sinister landscape of h.g
wells's scientific romance the island of
dr moreau
johnston becomes aware of our discomfort
and our fearfulness ripples through the
auditorium as we shift in our seats
lower our eyes and lose concentration
beatrice does not know what to make of
what she sees and feels it's all too
overwhelming
i leave the auditorium and my
grandmother and force myself back to the
university library and the script in
front of me
johnston reasserted control at the point
where the unknown seemed too strange
too wild for his audience
his lecture belonged to a larger
modernist project to teach the british
to view jamaica as a well-ordered
domesticated landscape
brimming with picturesque places
so he countered their unease by setting
his audience down by the cave river for
a picnic
the lecture struck a candy balance
between
thrilling his listeners
and offering comfort and reassurance
regularly reminding them that jamaica
was a benign and a healthful paradise
one of the fairest countries in the
habitable earth
a land of picturesque views and
unrivaled beauty
in his lecture
the phrase
in what other country could you find
was repeated
many times
jamaica
the audience were confidently assured
was a dreamland
jamaicans are revealed to be gardens
purveyors of abundance
bearers of the island's agricultural
riches for the dreamers consumption
presented in the neat clean attire that
everyone in edwardian britain would
recognize as the uniformed servants
these jamaicans are posed with yams
bananas and unhusked
coconuts
as they hold
balance and lift into view
gigantic examples of produce
viewers
are reassured
that jamaicans successfully handle
nature that otherwise could appear to be
out of control
offering up to the viewer the fruits of
their labor and their island
jamaicans become people
who like the landscape against which
they are posed
are managed
tamed
and domesticated
the population of the new jamaica is
safe
willing and eager to serve their
island's bounty to future tourists
johnston
and his flickering images held his
audience spellbound
picture exhibits not only fair types of
the ordinary domestic servant being
toned
but also good specimens of the jamaican
staff of life
the ubiquitous yam
weaving jamaicans and jamaican produce
seamlessly together
johnston's voice rose
his head swept the room and his eyes
sought to make direct contact
sorry sought to make direct contact
with each member of his audience
pausing for effect
before declaring
jamaica
to be the brightest jewel
in the british crown
if beatrice
my sister moored
and my great-grandmother rose were among
johnston's audience
they would have learned
that very poor
and female though they were
they owned jamaica
land
people
and produce
thank you
thank you so much hazel for that
absolutely wonderful talk
gosh um
i guess i
i would like to upload on behalf of the
uh audience thank you
um
and i guess we are ready for um any
questions
uh from the audience please go ahead and
type them in the q a
uh panel that appears on your screen
i do have one question i could share
from a participant i believe you had to
leave earlier
please go ahead ty
sure
uh
let's see so he had noted he taught
african history in the yale history
department in the late 1980s and then
some years later african ethnography and
anthropology he said some of us have
been working for the last 50 years or so
on the history and ethnography of what
was known in west africa as the bristol
coast that is a portion to the west of
the gold coast at the time corresponding
to what is today the ivory coast he asks
then has your work on bristol's history
extended to the bristol coast in west
africa
uh no
not other than just the the extraction
of uh forced labor not actually
in detail to the coast itself
other than to um
in my research obviously to come across
the ways in which the ecology
and the environment
of the coast was drastically changed
not only because the instruction of so
many millions of people but also because
of the way the environment and the
ecology had to change to feed our people
and um not only the forced labor but
also the sailors and the and the ships
um that were coming in so the actual
sort of growing um of
food to support those forts for example
um did change the ecology and the
environment um drastically but no my
book actually concentrates on the
relation between
the two islands
um
of britain and and and jamaican
um so hazel um i had a question if i may
um
you know i was curious about the
construction of the native
of the other
and how that
sort of fundamentally seems different
for the enslaved transported peoples
versus the colonials who were um
the imperial state established in india
for example
so the sort of the construction of who
is the other
obviously it's informed by very
different sort of power dynamics
still of domination but domination
versus enslavement so i was curious how
the
how you would see sort of the
reflection of these sorts of power
dynamics how different are they in
places like uh south asia southeast asia
like india for example
the british colonial kind of within
india you want me to talk about within
india or i mean because okay so
the book actually um it starts
uh impossible to work world war ii
britain and goes
all the way back
um to jamaica and then
ending up in in in britain again in the
middle of the uh 18th century
um
and the relations um
[Music]
the entanglements
are concentrated in those areas but in
each of those different historical
moments
you can see
um
different formations of the way in which
empire
jamaica being the main
focus actually comes home
so you know
during world war ii
um
for example
the
policing of
of bodies was very much about black
bodies
and white bodies
with within the metropole you know and
um the
one of the crises that i look at was
actually the crises the the brown baby
crises
they called it a crisis it was a it was
a sort of moral panic
and that was very much focused on the
children who were born of black american
troops who were based in britain
and um people who came from
the west indies basically um and that
was their great fear it wasn't actually
uh during world war ii
a fear from the indian subcontinent so
much because i think because
um
there weren't so many troops based there
it's all about
so
okay
so one of the things
about empire
is the way in which it managed all its
populations right all over the globe i
mean i talk a lot about how you know
winston churchill
said that britain stood alone
right
um after you know
against nazi germany which was a
completely absurd thing because they had
this huge empire and it was an
extraordinary war machine great where
you where is very very interesting i
think in terms of their management of
different
peoples is actually in the west indies
themselves
right i mean uh post-war britain is
something else but in the west indies
themselves um after
emancipation which wasn't actually in
emancipation
right
in 1834 to 38
um a number of uh people who had been on
the plantations working on the
plantations descendants of africans
walked away from the plantations
and that led to the british again
manipulating their population
and
importing indenturedly in the same ships
that they'd used for the enslaved
indentured labor from india
and in fact labor from china
there you see
new racial formations developing and a
whole new language and a whole new
sort of biopolitics and disciplining of
bodies for certain bodies to be doing
certain forms of labor and occupying
certain forms of position and so from
that point of view the west indies is
actually really you know
horrific but also interesting in terms
of what it actually
um it's very revolutionary
reveals about the british empire
in the metropole after world war ii
basically what happens in terms of
movements of my
generation um to become black british
is actually an alliance so you know the
black movement in britain is very
different to the black movement in the
us
yes because
populations from
the indians particularly the indian
subcontinent
and from the west indies become allied
under that term black
yes you know again and so the
anti-racist movement the black-led
anti-racist movement has that sort of
you know alliance
right and i guess each historical moment
is different there isn't a general you
know answer
and and then you're right and i think
that it's this alliance
between the
you know the south asian
the immigration from south asia
that kind of formed this alliance
with the flow of people from the west
indies
in england that alliance right yeah it
has a that alignment has been
very different
from
from the united states the organization
and the power of politics in the united
states and i dwell on those differences
because it goes back to that question of
identity with which i
which i began you know people think sort
of identity is something simple that
they carry around with them
um but i you know i very carefully look
at very different historical moments
and how that in fact is formed and
especially working with um you know
students in the u.s
you have to explain to them that black
doesn't mean the same thing
in different parts of the world race
doesn't mean the same thing in different
parts of the world at different moments
you have to sort of study how it's
articulated in particular places and
particular times and how it's resisted
too
right and and the fact i think uh when
am i right in uh taking away the point
that you know and this idea of identity
is not stable either because you reflect
off others and depending on where the
lines are drawn and how the lines have
drawn as who is the other
your identity gets it's very fluid it
gets reshaped all the time exactly
but i think the thing that you
wonderfully point out is that the
somehow
with all this shape-shifting
the power politics has remained
very steady and fixed right um
well the power of politics what actually
forms
the hegemonic power
politics can
can shift
but the question of you know
subordination we're still we're still
dealing with the aftermath of settler
colonialism you know so um and
imperialism and how those things work
their way through are very
important to to to understand absolutely
yeah and and i think that you know work
like yours is extremely timely because
at this moment right in my field so if
you look at what's happening in space
sciences now
you know we as a human species are still
not able to break out of this frame
of settler colonialism when we talk
about
landing on mars exploring the universe
etc right i mean we're not able to break
that frame
it's a fundamental relationship with
nature and other beings
um
that we really need to disrupt this um
well yes because it might in my new
project which is um which is sort of
rather different that's that's sort of
also exactly the point i mean the point
about understanding settler colonialism
is that it's you know yes it's the
domination of indigenous peoples of the
enslavement of peoples but it's also the
domination of the environment yeah and
you know the exploitation of various
ecologies so it's actually understanding
that settler colonial
settler colonialism is also itself
behind this extraordinary environmental
and you know catastrophic climate uh
crisis that we're that we are facing
absolutely absolutely
are there any other questions ty do you
see any other questions brilliant no i
think everyone's been enjoying this very
informative exchange between the two of
you
oh i mean there's so much to learn from
hazel um
i i could uh keep asking more but let me
let me i'll give a little bit of space
for people to uh
pipe up and ask
one of the things like that one of the
things i did want to say is that um
you know when i actually found
um
when i actually located the archives and
found out who
the owner was
of
those
enslaved that you saw in that in that
slave register
i also you know was asking some very
similar
questions which because he actually
turned out to be
the the son of a carpenter he went into
the british army um and deserts uh when
he's actually in in jamaica but again
i tried to think about how
he had to learn
to become a white man
in a colony how he actually had to learn
you know um
and adapt to the extraordinary power
he was given the the the right to
brutalize
the right to rape
because of his white skin right and so
you know those historical circumstances
were very different to those of a
grandmother in bristol but thinking
about how
um
people's environment
and how they engage with that
how that what the question of whiteness
um
again is something that is you know that
that is taught to people and that they
actually adopt and then they actually
have to sort of you know practice it
right um you know one of the reasons i
actually decided to think about this
particular aspect of of the book tonight
and about the question of of of
whiteness
is in fact because of what we've been
facing where i live right here you know
in guildford which was a white
supremacist attempt to take over the
board of education
um and you know
we had the elections yesterday and thank
god they because people were very well
organized they actually lost
um you know two to one but it is a
strategy
that is in fact
very very prominent now and guildford
was being used as a way to sort of test
how this sort of extremism
of how these senses of
whiteness being under threat
you know because of sort of
multicultural curriculums can actually
be used
to mobilize white supremacist politics
now and i think we don't we don't talk
about whiteness enough
um yeah i mean it's perniciousness yes
and i i think and it's resilience this
concept is survived
as you said it mutates a little bit but
it surfaces
uh you know anywhere there's a minor you
know there's a little bit of room and it
surfaces and there is resonance the
scary part
is that there is resonance even now when
we believe there's a lot more awareness
so there's a very nice question from
megan fountain who's asking did you take
any inspiration from novels as well as
from the historical archives oh yes the
um you know the
the book is the book is full um in fact
of sort of various explicit and less
explicit uh nods uh to novels absolutely
particular you know i mean writers like
michael and archie and
kaz phillips and even actually even jane
austen i talk about a lot and virginia
woolf um
but
you know in terms of trying to um
deal
with
people who didn't leave records
whose records weren't in the archives
the archives is full of you know the um
the records of the wealthy those who
write diaries all the write the
plantation records or whatever but when
you're dealing with massive silences
it's that case of sort of translating
some very complex historical research
into ways in which a reader can imagine
the lives of people and that um you know
that is where novelists are actually
extraordinary especially novelists who
really think seriously about you know
about history like on darchi and and kaz
phillips yes
uh and um
there's another question from mary
marshall clark what about andrea levy
the long song
all of andre er
andrea levy's yeah work i mean i i have
read and i'm deeply indebted to abs
absolutely yeah
and particularly you know in the in the
second world war
i think the way in which she
she talks about the relationships
between
um you know white women and and black
military personnel is extraordinarily
revealing yeah absolutely
um are there any other questions
i don't see any further one before we
close i'm really tempted to ask one more
question hazel if i may
um
how do you see
this um
you know i don't want to use the word
reconciliation because i have to say
there are days when i'm optimistic and
there are days when i'm not so
do you see that
how do you see the way forward how are
we going to settle
these uh
these issues of
um
identity
power
power relations um
and you know we all aspire for equity
and equality of opportunity and all of
this so how are we really going to how
are we going to transcend all of this
can we
oh pray if only i had the answer to that
i mean heavens above
it's it's what we are some of us are
struggling for
um every single day um
you know in our work in our research and
our politics there there is no
um simple reconciliation i mean there
has to be
um
you know a massive
transformation i think of of imagination
um and a number of people you know a
number of historians filmmakers artists
and because i think visual art is that
is also very very important i are trying
to accomplish that
um particularly a number of sort of
indigenous
um you know writers like roxanne dumbo
ortiz and nick asti's or whatever and
um
and raul peck's new series
you know um exterminate the brutes we
have to we have to
completely radically understand the way
in which particularly you know this
country the americas
um
are
so profoundly still shaped
by
stolen lands the decimation of
indigenous peoples
the absolute um
you know ignorance because we really
need to recover a lot of those lost
knowledges
that set the colonialism decided you
know that were
worthless whether it's about the
environment the ecology others way to
live but the indebtedness
the deep deep indebtedness
um to the horrors um
that settler colonialism understood i
mean i think we've only just begun yeah
and then
you know
yeah and it is a grand collusion right
because in a in a society that you know
capitalist society voraciously
capitalist society
these are the underpinnings so
obviously
yes and these and and so and the
voraciousness you know continues um
indigenous peoples black people they are
still they still live in the most
polluted
areas right they are
still considered waste if you like um in
terms of sort of corporate corporate
power they are
you know disposable they can have
drinking water that isn't fit to drink
so these inequalities
um established under settler colonialism
continue you can see that in the the
pandemic figures you know who actually
suffered the most right and so
you know
there is no easy reconciliation there
but i think
you know um
[Music]
i think white supremacy
has has to be brought to account
yeah
i mean it it's for me the tenacity of
white supremacy is what
is shocking
um i mean i shouldn't be shocked but you
know um yeah um
but um but i i think we have no choice
but to confront
understand and uh completely um
reorient
our view and you know i really hope that
you know the climate crisis and the
growing political awareness of all these
inequities
historical that resonate to the present
day i really hope they combine and they
you know they provide new tinder right
that this combination of the way in
which we've ravaged nature as well
right i don't know uh and that is sort
of well the indigenous presence at the
climate conference in glasgow is
incredibly strong
um and extremely articulate i mean
saying the most you know if only if only
people would listen if only people would
listen to them
anyway um uh we i could go on and on and
uh
would be extremely selfish of me but um
are there any other questions ty do you
have any
thank you
it's just um
what a talk
i'm sorry i'm frankly obsessed with it
it was just phenomenal so thank you
thank you and thank you everybody for
you know all the support and stuff so
thank you very much it was it was great
thank you so much um
welcome priya thank you for the
invitation
most welcome